Okay, go. Yeah, Podcast-UFO. Du heisst hier Stefan, das Fun steht für Spaß, wir machen dich kaputt, deine Rhymes sind aus Glas.
Wir sind im Tonstudio einer professionellen Firma, ist das nicht was, wir kommen von unten ganz nach oben. Egal was ihr wollt, wir haben eine Oboe dabei, sie steht hier, ihr könnt sie nicht sehen, das ist ein Podcast, wir sind Podcaster. Ja, und ich glaube, wir wollen heute eine richtig geile Folge abliefern. Oder auch nicht, denn wir haben Kiefern in unserem Garten daheim, denn wir sind Spießer. Und es war irgendwie in als Lehr, aber auch ganz nett gerimt. Folge 12 ist die Nummer, wir machen das Dutzend voll. Egal was noch kommt, wir sind kein Proll. Wir sind die Besten in der Podcast-Szene, ist auch nicht so schwer, denn sie hat noch keine Szene. Es gibt nicht so viele. Es reimt sich nicht. Naja, ist okay. Wir sind das Salz in der Podcast-Suppe, egal was ihr macht, ihr seid unsere Puppe. Wir holen das Money raus, schmeissen damit Rum, egal was ihr wollt, ich trinke recht selten Rum. We're out, hey, danke. Nee, das sollten wir lassen. Die meisten Rhymes werden wir noch rausschneiden. Das war nur eine Ansage, das hat keinen Rhyme. Okay, mal was... Wir machen das mal richtig. Das Podcast-Ufo ist jetzt gelandet, wir wollen nicht, dass ihr in der Podcast-Wüste strandet.
Oh yeah, das war schon richtig gut. Aber ich glaube, uns fehlt noch der Mut, denn wir müssen richtig selbstbewusst auftreten.
Nicht so wie zwei Lappen, die vergessen, was sie sagen van Beethoven mit Can't Live Without You. Schön, dass ihr wieder dabei seid beim Podcast UFO.
Herzlich willkommen.
Mir gegenüber sitzt heute Stefan die Tatze, Titzel! Hey Titzel, hey, was geht? Gegenüber von mir sitzt der einzig wahre, der grossartige, der heute wunderschöne Florentil! Ro, Ro, Ro, Ro, Ro! Ja, wir haben leider keine Themen dabei, deswegen müssen wir relativ schnell den Impromodus übergehen. Ganz kurz, das ist letztendlich. Wir sind so aufgeregt. Wir sind so aufgeregt. Lass mich erklären, warum wir aufgeregt sind. Erstens sind wir aufgeregt, weil wir das erste Mal seit zwölf Folgen, wie genau in der ersten Folge, wieder im gleichen Raum sind, Stefan und ich. Das ist der Klang von Körperkontakt. Und das ist sogar so, dass wir die gleichen Sachen dann haben.
Und es ist wirklich verdammt heiß hier drin.
Machen wir mal das Fenster auf.
Wir hören sogar, wir müssen das Fenster aufmachen.
Es ist keine Lüge, wir sitzen gegenüber voneinander.
Das heißt, die Folge wird herausragend gut.
Puh, ja, ja, ja, okay.
Wenn wir Themen hätten.
Bei uns ist ein Special Guest, wie kann ich ihn am besten anmoderieren, er war in Sex-Film der grosse Star, der Star der Herzen, er ist klein, er ist rund, es ist R2D2, herzlich willkommen R2D2!
Und falls ihr euch fragt, warum wir heute ein bisschen aufgeregt und nervös sind und so ein bisschen das Glitzern in den Augen haben, wir sind elektrisiert, denn tatsächlich seit zwölf Folgen sind wir genau wie in der ersten Folge im selben Raum. Das ist der Klang von Körperkontakt. Ist das nicht schön? Menschen zu berühren hat auch so eine Magie. Das ist was ganz fantastisches. Aber wir sollten es jetzt in der nächsten Stunde nicht nochmal machen, wir sollten uns nicht mehr berühren. Ne, müssen wir auch gar nicht, denn wir haben genug Themen wieder an Land gebaggert, sozusagen um die die Stunde wieder mal zu füllen. Wir haben viele Nachrichten bekommen von euch. Wir haben letztes Woche das erste Mal ausprobiert, Marketing zu betreiben im Podcast. Es kam erstaunlich viel zurück. Es hat tatsächlich sehr gut funktioniert. Es war ja grösstensalig Quatsch, was wir geschrieben haben. Es war eigentlich, es war noch niemals für den Gag, es war einfach Quatsch. Und irgendwie fragt man sich dann doch, warum wir dann so viele Follower am Ende hatten. Es ist aber auch, vielleicht ist einfach die Taktik so aufgegangen, sehr viel schreiben, mit sehr viel, gibt auch sehr viel Resonanz. Ja, aber wenn man sehr viel schreibt, trifft man halt auch viele und dann werden Leute aufmerksam. Ist erst einmal egal, wie man Leute erreicht hat, sondern man hat die Attention. Man sagt ja auch, jede PR ist gute PR, sagt man auch. Ist Quatsch, aber man sagt es. Ich glaube, Bär, das waren Bären. Bär. Jeder Bär ist ein guter Bär. Jeder Bär ist ein Bär zu viel. Es gibt keine schlechten Bären, glaube ich. Naja, ich glaube, es gibt ja... War Bruno, der erschossen wurde? Kann nicht so gut gewesen sein. Warum wurde der erschossen? Kann nicht so gut gewesen sein, ich weiß nicht, weil der halt im... Der Eisbär. Nein, das war Knut. Ach so, ich rieche. Der Knut wurde erschossen. Was ist da passiert? Alle beiden Bären, die es gibt, die es niemals so bekanntlich geschafft haben. Ralph by Shooting. Was istnten geschafft haben, alle beiden bekannten Bären erstmal alles durcheinander geschmissen werden.
Wir haben diese Woche eine Menge Tiergags rausgehauen. Vielleicht habt ihr es mitbekommen, den kleinen Hype Hashtag Giraffen Tweets. Wir haben noch eine ganze Menge Tiergags, die wir versuchen, ganz punktuell hier und da einzustreiten.
Aber Podcast UFO wäre nicht das Podcast UFO, wenn wir nicht natürlich auch ein bisschen was für unsere Geldbörse tun würden, denn ... This episode is brought to you by Booster Energy Drink. Booster, get your energy. Ich muss auch trinken und sagen, wie es schmeckt. Ja, es ist ganz gut. Es schmeckt okay. Es kommen hier ständig Leute ins Studio rein und gucken uns dumm an, deswegen sind wir tatsächlich ein bisschen verwirrt.
Aber falls die Gags in den letzten Folgen nicht so gut waren für euch, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass wir Booster noch nicht entdeckt haben, der Energydrink, der boostet.
Einfach, ihr gebt euch einen Boost, egal was ihr gerade tut, nehmt einfach einen Boost, die Gags sind schlecht, boostet die Gags.
Ganz kurz, wenn irgendwer bei Netto arbeitet, der kann uns vielleicht so ein Endorsement von Booster Energydrinks besorgen können, das wäre wahnsinnig toll. Wir trinken das Zeug wahnsinnig gerne, es schmeckt ein bisschen süss, aber vielleicht kann man mit den Leuten reden. Und im Endeffekt ist es so, dass wir wahnsinnig gerne gesponsert werden würden. Wir würden gerne Werbung machen, also in diesem Feld nochmal an die Schwarmintelligenz appellieren, wenn die Ideen haben, wofür wir Werbung machen könnten, um ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen.
Ich meine, Leute, wir haben es beide nicht so dicke. Das hört man an unseren Stimmen, wir haben es beide nicht so dicke. Wir sind arm dran, wir können froh sein, wenn wir es überhaupt ins Studio schaffen, mal eine Woche. Also bitte, wenn ihr da irgendwas für uns habt, sehr gerne. Es gibt verschiedene Sorten, wir haben uns für zwei Sorten entschieden. Ich zum Beispiel habe Greengrass. Und das sagt alles über dich. Das sagt alles über dich. Das ist die langweiligste Sorte. Ich kenne nicht viele Sorten von irgendwelchen Dingen, aber wenn etwas so heisst, Greengrass, das ist das Langweiligste der Welt. Als erstes Assoziere ist grünes Gras, das ist eine schöne Liegewiese, ist ein Energy Drink, genau das brauche ich jetzt. Und wie heisst da einer?
Thunderstorm. In mir brennt gerade ein Thunderstorm hoch. Man merkt, was es mit uns macht. Die Jokes sind noch nicht geboostet, das ist ein bisschen das Problem, wir müssen sie tatsächlich noch boosten. Es dauert zwölf Sekunden, bis es boostet. Über Asterix. Das ist ein sehr guter Gag, aber halt visuell. Das können wir jetzt eigentlich ständig sagen, das ist ein verdammt guter Gag, ihr könnt ihn nur leider nie sehen. Leute, was hier grad abgeht, ne? Ich sehe gerade vor mir, ich beschreibe euch jetzt, was ihr sehen könntet, wenn ihr hier wärt. Florentin Will in einem Bikini, in einer Hollywood-Schaukel. Mit zwei Kilo Erdnuss, oder? Und warum auch immer trägt er ein Schlüpfer auf dem Kopf. Ich habe noch nicht rausgekommen, warum, aber ich habe auch nicht nachgefragt. Mein, komischerweise. Er wedelt mit einem Umschlag in der Hand mir entgegen. Jetzt kämmt er sich durch sein Haar, das leicht im Wind weht, man hört die Brise. Ich habe tatsächlich Post bekommen. Er hat Post bekommen, er hat einen Umschlag. Er hat Post bekommen und ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist und ich möchte ganz kurz ein bisschen ausholen. Und zwar war ich, um es ganz kurz zu machen, vor einiger Zeit war ich in Tübingen, war ich dort eingeladen zu einer Talkrunde und da bin ich am Flughafen angekommen, am Stuttgarter Flughafen und dort begegneten mir nicht nur die Veranstalter dieser Talkrunde, sondern auch eine Fotografin des Flughafens, die gesagt hat, guten Tag, wir sind vom Flughafenmagazin, können wir ein Foto von ihnen machen? What? Warum will denn ein Flughafenmagazin, die haben nicht verwechselt, die dachten, du wärst Dickbach. Dachte ich mir tatsächlich auch sofort. Oh, fuck, viel zu früh, viel zu spät. Wenn Sie diesen Podcast in 2022 hören, werden Sie vielleicht gelacht haben. Nein, auf jeden Fall haben Sie ein Foto von mir gemacht für das Flughafenmagazin Flugblatt, heisst das, weil es ja Flugzeug ist. Flyer, warum nicht Flyer? Genau, also. Das funktioniert so nicht, du musst auch, wenn du bei dem Motto lachen. Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, w warst in den Flops der Flughafen. Nee, und ich bin wahrscheinlich nächste Woche und die Veranstalter haben am Flughafen gefragt, ob sie da drehen dürfen und die Veranstalter haben gesagt, wenn die da dreht, ist das ja wahrscheinlich ein krasser Typ und der da vorbei. Und deswegen wurde ich mit einem Star verwechselt, mehr oder weniger. Also auf jeden Fall, jetzt habe ich dieses Flugblatt tatsächlich bekommen, in dem ich wahrscheinlich abgedruckt bin. Ehrlich jetzt? Hier steht auch eine nette Botschaft, lieber Florentin, Seite 20, ein Traum. Dir für die Zukunft viel Glück und bis irgendwann. Mit besten Grüßen aus Tübingen. Auch schön gut, dass Sie das Bedürfnis haben, dir viel Glück zu wünschen in der Zukunft. Weil sehr offensichtlich haben Sie gemerkt. Vielen Dank, es war ein schöner
Abend und er wird immer besser, auch nachwirkend noch. Und auf Seite 20, so weiter, ganz gut. Ich bin ganz gespannt. Ich lasse es dich mal lesen, auf Seite 20. Ich bin tatsächlich nicht der einzige Star, der es ins Magazin geschafft hat. Ich habe schon ein bisschen geguckt. Du kennst schon, du weißt schon, warum was passiert ist. Nee, ich weiß nicht, was passiert ist, aber ich habe es gerade nur gesehen. Es ist tatsächlich eine sehr unangenehme Situation, wenn dir jemand mit Fotoapparat
entgegentritt und dir sagt, kann ich ein Foto fürs Flughafenmagazin? Du siehst auch so aus, du bist zwar Schauspieler, aber das sieht so aus, als ob du nicht keinen Bock darauf hast, dass gerade ein Foto von dir gemacht wird. Ich war komplett perplex in der Situation. What? Weißt du, wer direkt gegenüber von dir ist, wer direkt über dir ist, der Artikel für ein Foto?
Wer?
Lionel Richie.
What?
Lionel Richie. Ich bin auf einer Seite mit Lionel Richie.
Wie geil ist das denn?
Und dein Foto ist genauso groß wie seins.
Also ich lese vor.
Also liest bitte erstmal alle anderen vor.
Ich lese erstmal alle anderen vor.
Lionel Richie vom Flughafen Köln-Bonn kommend landete der US-amerikanische Soulsänger, Songwriter und Musikproduzent Lionel Richie am General Aviation General des baden-württembergischen Landesflughafens. Bei seiner Tour All the Hits All Night Long, die ihn quer durch Europa führt, trat der 65-jährige Oscar und Grimme-Preis … Oscar? Oscar und Grimme-Preis! Nein, ich habe nicht versprochen. Oscar und Grammy-Preis. Sorry. Ihr auch gut. Daher hat Oscar und Grammy-Preis Traeger vor kurzem auch bei einem Konzert in der Stuttgarter Schleierhalle auf. Dort gab er vor einem begeisterten Publikum sowohl Klassiker wie Angel und Say You, Say Me. Ich versuche die ganze Zeit den Text zu übersetzen. Yes, together. Als neue Hits zum Besten, als auch neue Hits zum Besten. Wollen wir mal unsere Rubrik starten, unbeantwortete Fragen der Musikgeschichte. Ich finde, Lionel Richie hat ja eine Frage gestellt, die nie beantwortet wurde. Hello, is it you you're looking for? Wurde nie beantwortet, tatsächlich. Is it me you're looking for? Is it me you're looking for? Ja, genau, solche Songs werfen ja immer Fragen auf, die aber nicht beantwortet werden, die einfach nie beantwortet werden, genauso wie What is love? Ich habe nie eine Antwort darauf bekommen. Vielleicht sollten wir alle diese Fragen mal kurz mit einem Satz beenden. Ja, okay. Is it me you're looking for? Nein. Offensichtlich nicht. What is love? It's chemical. Look it up, look it up, you idiot. Look it up, what the fuck was Wikipedia made for? Ja, genau. Boost your fucking questions, motherfucker, boost it! Mit Buster. Mir fallen aber jetzt auch keine Fragen ein. Was wurde denn noch vielen Dank für die Rosen? Nicht wirklich eine Frage, nein. Überhaupt gar nicht, überhaupt gar nicht. Boost your energy, okay. This gag was brought to you by Booster Energy Drink, Booster. If it wasn't funny enough, just boost it up! Get this fucking party started! Get this fucking boosted, get the party boosted!
Don't start if you can boost!
Also ohne Scheiss, Thunderstorm ist der absolute Shit! Okay, wer ist noch auf der Seite? Okay, das war wirklich, Leine Ritchie war schon die, ähm, es ist, ich sehe auch gar nichts hier, der Raum ist dunkel, wir sitzen in einer Dunkelkammer, Darkroom. Christoph Sonntag.
Ich warte auf nichts.
Sag mir überhaupt nichts. Du bist der High-Society-Experte, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Comedian Christoph Sonntag war kürzlich in Terminal 1, auch immer gut, dass sie sagen, genau wo sie waren. Ja klar, für die Flughafenfans ist das natürlich wichtig, ja. In Terminal 1 des Stuttgart-Flughafen unterwegs. Und hat ein Toonfish-Sandwich für 68 Euro gegriffen. Für seine Sendung Sonntag am Freitag, Sonntag am Freitag auch sehr lustiger Name, die in der SWR-Landesschau läuft, rätte der gebürtige Weiblinger am Airport. Ganz klassisch verabschiedete er sich schließlich mit den Worten, so, dann war des auch geschwätzt. Wow, schlechter Text, schlecht performt. Das ist die Stefan-Titze-Garantie. Erstmal tut es mir leid, wenn meine Nase läuft, dann habe ich einen Bonbon im Mund und dann sehe ich nicht, was ich da vorlese und ich kann keinen Dialekt.
Das war ja die denkbar ungünstigste Situation für den Text.
Was diese Performance nicht für dich nicht gut genug genug? Just booste es auf!
Boost your coughing, you're not sick enough, just boost it up with booster. Ich hab auch Husten davon bekommen.
Do you want to call out your Lunge?
Then boost it, beschleunige es with booster energy drink.
Do you want to get worse in English?
Just boost it, beschleunige es with Booster Energy Drink. Do you want to get worse in English? Just boost it. Booster failures. Just boost them. Alles wird, mit Booster wird alles dramatisiert, alle schlechten Eigenschaften, alle guten, alle Extreme geschrieben. Der folgende Gag wird Ihnen präsentiert von Booster. Weißt du, was ich mache, wenn ich im Lotto gewinne? Ich kaufe mir ein Thunfisch-Sandwich im Flughafen. War das nicht peinlich genug für Sie, dass... Okay, weiter geht's. Okay, kommen wir mal gleich zu mir. Ja, bitte, es kommt noch ein langweiliger Gäste. Okay, aber... Florentin Will, Nachwuchskomiker Florentin Will … Also, wir analysieren jedes Wort. Nachwuchskomiker … ist okay. Ja, ist okay. Sagt noch nichts aus. Nachwuchskomiker Florentin Will reiste aus Berlin über den Flughafen Stuttgart nach Tübingen. Dort trat er bei einer Veranstaltung des Studentischen Kulturvereins Querfeld ein auf. Der gebürtige Münchner wurde 2013 in Frank Elstners Ausbildungsprogramm Moderatoren von morgen aufgenommen.
Außerdem ist er in der Fernsehshow, Neomagazin Royal sowie im Internet bei Sui TV und auf YouTube zu sehen. Also es schliesst sich schon mal aus.
SuiTV ist nicht auf YouTube, sehr gut erkannt.
Ja, ist erst falsch geschrieben und zweitens ist es nicht auf YouTube, er ist da zu sehen und auf YouTube. Ja, das stimmt. Aber wow, ich stelle mir immer die Leute vor, die diese Prospekte machen und einfach so schwitzen jeden Tag in der Redaktion. Hoffentlich kommt ein Star. Wir haben jetzt schon acht Beiträge über Laufbänder gemacht, wir haben die Mülleimer schon viermal gecheckt,
wir haben die fucking Dosen gezählt, die hier jeden Tag eingebaut werden.
Wir kennen jeden Slackautomaten, die Nummern auswendig, wir wissen, welches Produkt, zu welcher Nummer kommt, wir können es blind wählen.
Ja, wir haben schon fünfmal ausgerechnet, wie die Leute abgezockt werden, wenn sie hier Sachen einkaufen, wir haben alle schon mal gemacht, alles, nichts Zoll, wir kennen alle Zollbeamten rückwärts.
Wir kennen alle Zollwitze, kennst du einen Zöllnerwitz?
Ja, warum steht ein Pilz im Wald?
Folgende Pointe wird Ihnen präsentiert von Booster Energy Drink.
Booster! Woo! Schmal die Tannenzapfen.
Es ist jetzt meine neue Art, wenn ich nicht auf etwas Antwort habe.
Auch schwer verständlich tatsächlich, aber hat mir dafür ganz gut gefallen.
Kannst du noch ein bisschen leiser sein?
Nebenan wird hier...
Kann unser Tontechniker bitte aufhören zu onanieren?
Es lenkt ein bisschen ab gerade.
Die Aufnahme ist ruiniert, wir können von vorne anfangen.
Mal Spaß.
War eh nicht gut, wir fangen da mal neu an.
Der Rap war ganz gut.
Jetzt haben wir uns gerade nicht ans Skript gehalten.
Füßte ein.
Was wir denn nicht wissen...
Warte mal, was steht da...
Also unser Techniker...
Du sagst, der Techniker soll aufhören zu onanieren. Genau, das lenkt ab. So. So, bei mir steht jetzt… Bei mir steht nichts? Steht auf. Okay. Hä? Ach so, die Nummer. Okay, warte mal. Warte, ganz kurz. Hast du die Bälle hier? Ganz kurz, wo habe ich die hingefahren? So alle drei dabei, oder was? Ja, da und? Wolltest du gerade das Erlebnis des Dinge aus dem Rucksack holen verstärken, indem du dein Mikrofon in den Rucksack steckst? Und dann aber gerührt, ich habe die Rührbewegung gemacht. Ich mache es nochmal. Das ist das Beste, was ich je gehört habe. Das machen ja Leute auch immer bei einer Kochshow, ne? Anstatt umzurühren, stecken die die Kamera in den Topf und rühren mit der Kamera um, damit der Zuschauer weiss, wie es ist. So stelle ich mir auch... So stelle ich mir vor, wenn ich etwas wäre, was in den Rucksack gelegt worden wäre. Diese Kreativitätslosigkeit wurde ihm präsentiert von Booster. Booster Energy Drink, boost your fucking creativity. Weisst du, was ich mich mal gefragt habe? Ich habe mich gefragt, ob sich Leute, die uns hören, sich nicht manchmal fragen, ob wir immer noch wir sind oder ob nicht mittlerweile Stimminimitatoren unsere Plätze eingenommen haben. Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich ein grosses Problem. Das Vertrauen ist einfach noch nicht da. Es kann niemand so authentisch husten wie Stefan Titzel.
Du kennst es ja bestimmt, wenn du irgendwie einen Radiominerator oft hörst und du hast eine gewisse Vorstellung davon, wie er aussieht und wie er sich verhält. Und meistens wird diese Vorstellung total enttäuscht, wenn du dann tatsächlich siehst, wie der Radiomoderator aussieht. Weil meistens hat es einen Grund, warum Leute im Radio moderieren und nicht etwa im Fernsehen, weil sie einfach fucking hässliche Leute sind. Ja, das stimmt schon. Hässliche Leute werden ihnen präsentiert, von Booster. Tatsächlich ist es jetzt, dass die meisten Leute mein Gesicht kennen, aber dein Gesicht nicht. Und ich habe tatsächlich mit einer Hörerin geredet, die genau dieses Erlebnis hatte, die unter dem Podcast immer gehört hat. Und dann hat sie gesagt, jetzt habe ich mal diesen Stefan Titzler, habe ich mir mal angeschaut auf Facebook. Titzler. Und ich habe mir das ganz anders vorgestellt. Ich dachte, er wäre 30 und hätte Kinder. Und das war die erste Mal so gut. Auch so detailliert auch so. Ja, und vor allem. Ich dachte, er war dreissig, hätte zwei Kinder, ein Jünger und ein Mädchen, die heißen Tim und Marie, und sie gingen die neun A des fünf. Nein, das war so knapp! Das war so knapp, das war ganz cool. Das war so gut. Versagen in letzter Sekunde mit Booster. Booster. Aber tatsächlich frage ich mich, wie sich das geäussert hat, einfach der Glaube, dass du Kinder hast. Wo kam das rüber? Ist es deine Altersweisheit, ist es deine Reife? Was ist das denn gerade? Do you want to die of liver damage? Just drink Booster! Ich habe in den ersten Folgen jetzt auch nicht gerade wie der super weise Typ gewirkt, der ansatzweise die Fähigkeit hat, Kinder zu erziehen. Und deswegen verstehe ich auch gar nicht, wo das herkommt. Ich habe ja nicht einmal von Kindern gesprochen. Ich bin sehr weit weg von Kindern. Kannst du dir vorstellen, Kinder zu haben? Ja. Ein junger Mädchen, sie sollen Tim und Marie heißen, in die 9a des Friedrich-Ebert-Gymnasiums in Kassel zu gehen. Diese Pause wurde präsentiert von Booster. Ohne Scheisse, ich würde echt gern für Booster auch Geld bekommen von denen. Ja, aber... Integere Marke. Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen das Padina-Rodzinski-Syndrom. Padina-Rodzinski hat ja... Oh, du hast wirklich für alles einen Namen. Du hast auch wirklich auf alles eine Antwort. Stimmt, ja.
Seinen Podcast-Kommoderator zu verurteilen, der auf alles eine Antwort hat.
Das ABC der schlechtesten Komoderator. Das ist ein bisschen der Helmut Karasek-Faktor.
Ne, aber tatsächlich...
Du hast das Circus Halligalli-Syndrom schon erklärt.
Du sollst das Buch rausbringen, das Syndrom, für die du Namen.
Stimmt, ich eigentlich meine ganzen Wortneuschöpfungen...
Das sind nur Syndromen. Nein, ich bin es an, zum Beispiel von William Shakespeare zum Beispiel. Der hat ja bekanntermaßen tausend, zwei... Shakespeare, Shakespeare, peer us together, naturally, flames to dust, lovers to friends, why do all good things come to a puncher? To no end uns, kein Ende. Aber zum Beispiel, William Shakespeare hat ja 1200 neue Worte sich ausgedacht und ich finde diesen Schaffensworts einfach so gut. Weißt du, wenn der Partner gerade nicht spricht, dann schaut er einfach irgendwo hin, wo gerade irgendwas flimmert. Einfach ein Leuchten der Windschirm muss er hingucken. Viel schlimmer, auf die Uhr habe ich geguckt. Aber es ist halt, weißt du, das ist viel schlimmer, wenn man sich auf die Uhr zu gucken, als ein relativ peinliches Syndrom. Das ist so ein bisschen... Wie ein Stefan-Tietz-Syndrom. Sag's ruhig, wie es ist. Okay, nein, William Shakespeare hat 1200 neue Worte entdeckt, und ich finde immer den Moment so magisch, wo er das das erste Mal benutzt hat, wo er das das erste Mal gesagt hat, irgendwas, und die Leute einfach nur, what, was war das? Aber es hat sich trotzdem aus irgendeinem Grund durchgesetzt. Trotzdem hatten die Leute Bock, es durchzusetzen. Genauso wie die erste Person, die irgendwie die Umarmung erfunden hat, wollten Leute einfach dann irgendwie weitermachen und sagen, hey, das ist echt eine total krasse Angelegenheit, es hat sich über die ganze Welt verbreitet. Oder Leute... Oh Gott, ich kann das Booster. Ich will auf das Booster... Alter, wir haben Folge 12 und das die Geschichte schon bestimmt zweimal erzählt. In Shakespeare. Oh Gott, ey, Alter, meine Zunge ist weg. Wanna boost your repetition? Booster! Du kannst Booster nicht sehr lange... Man darf Booster, das ist ein Cooster-Advice, nicht länger als zehn Sekunden im Mund halten. Ich glaube, ich habe keine Zunge mehr. Man wandelt sich dann zu TNT, ein bisschen problematisch. Es entwickelt sich so eine ganz Nitroglycerin oder so, es ätzt einfach die Innereien weg. Ja, ja. Nein, aber um noch mal ganz kurz zurückzukommen, ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, wo ich bin, tut mir leid, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt, weil ich bin ein bisschen nervös. Ich bin ein bisschen nervös. Das Palina-Rosinski-Problem ist folgendes. Palina Rosinski hat bei MTV Home immer Red Bull getrunken. MTV Home immer Red Bull getrunken. Und irgendwann hat sie dann gesagt, so hey, an Red Bull geschrieben, hey, wollt ihr mir nicht Geld dafür geben, dass ich Werbung für Red Bull mache? Weil ich trinke ja immer Red Bull und hat Red Bull gesagt, nee, du trinkst ja so oder so Red Bull. Warum solleniße. Warum sollen wir dir noch Werbung dafür geben, wenn du sowieso so oder so Werbung für uns machen willst? Alter, aber wenn du schon einen Namen dafür hast, für dieses Problem, was du schon erkannt, analysiert und proaktiv bekämpfst. Abgeschlossen, bin ich abgeschlossen. Trotzdem hast du nichts dagegen getan, dass wir jetzt Booster-Werbung machen, obwohl wir eigentlich von denen gesponsert werden wollen. Ja, ich hätte mich da ein bisschen in Sackgasse mal vorbereitet, tut mir leid. leid. Sackgassen, wer den präsentiert, von Lidl, einfach mal ein bisschen. Sackgasse war auch so ein Wort, kennst du das, wenn du als Kind, was ist mit dir los heute? Du bist heute den ganzen Tag schon so ein bisschen, ich möchte mal ganz auf eine emotionale Ebene geben, weil wir sind heute tatsächlich beide sehr emotional angespannt. Ich habe alles von der Booster. Und warum bist du heute so schlecht drauf? Ich bin gar nicht schlecht. Erzähl mal. Ich bin gar nicht schlecht. Was heute passiert? Heute Morgen, weißt du, da bin ich in die Studio gekommen, das Erste war, nein, ich bin durch die Tür und dann kam ein Eimer, wo Fische waren, das ist auf mich runtergefallen. Und unter mir war so ein X und ich dachte mir, hey, das war so ein X aus Kräftpapier, ich wollte es abmachen, dann ist ein Eimer auf mich runtergefallen. Dann gehe ich weiter, eine Bananenschale, ich rutsche natürlich darauf aus und dann gehe ich weiter und dann wollte ich die Tür aufmachen zum Autorenraum, da ist die Türklinke natürlich unter Strom gesetzt. Ich habe mir Herzinfarkt bekommen, wurde dann wiederbelebt durch Booster, Booster Energy Drink. Boost your stories with Booster. Dann bin ich weitergegangen, wurde ich wieder zum Leben erweckt, alle waren schon ein bisschen, oh Gott, der Scherz ist wohl bis zum Wald gegangen, ich habe mich auf meinen Fußskizzen gesetzt. Und es ging den ganzen Tag so weiter. Und dann fragst du mich jetzt ernsthaft, warum das nach hinten losgegangen ist. Also natürlich ist man eine schlechte Bauer. Moment, ganz kurz. Ich dachte, du hast heute tatsächlich einen Fischwitz gemacht. Und ich dachte, du hast diese ganze Anekdote jetzt nur angefangen, um einen Fischwitz zu bringen. Dass du sagen kannst, heute ist mir ein Eimer mit Fischen auf den Kopf gefallen. Apropos Fische. Ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass man die nie länger angucken kann, ohne nicht seinen Mund dazu zu bewegen oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung? Was war das immer für ein Fischgeg, den ich gemacht habe? Ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht mehr. Ich sollte mir aufschreiben. Man sollte, ich möchte gerne hier an der Stelle mal eine Sekretärin, ne, wie heißt das, eine Stellunggrafin, nenne ich gerne, die mir, die immer den ganzen Tag hinter mir herläuft und aufschreibt, was ich sage. Ich glaube, es kommt nämlich viel Grütz raus, wenn ich wirklich gute Sachen sagen sollte, aber ich glaube, dass ich zwischen den Aufnahmeprozessen, also wenn wir jetzt die Aufnahme pausieren würden, würde ich sehr schlaue Sachen sagen. Und das sind die Momente, die hätte ich gerne aufgeschrieben, damit ich sie dann in den wichtigen Momenten hätte sagen können, zum Beispiel. Ja. Wenn es darauf ankommt, kannst du es nicht. Jetzt ist es gerade. Ich habe Auswurf. Ich habe Husten und Auswurf. Was ist denn hier los, ey? Das kann nicht wahr sein, dass du jetzt hier komplett... Ist es die Luft, ist es Booster, ich weiß es nicht. Stefan macht ja gerade den Uwe Barschel und ich muss versuchen, die Situation noch irgendwie zu retten. Du hast ja gerade die Pollen, die Heike Mack hat und ich weiß aber gar nicht, was soll das denn? In der Namensbattle. Naja.D2 hat auch keine Meinung zu gar nichts. Ich find's immer erstaunlich, dass so ein Charakter wie R2-D2 eigentlich durch sechs Filme durchgeschleppt wird, obwohl er nie wirklich ... Ich meine, er hat allen mal den Arsch gerettet zwischendurch. Er ist schon wichtig für die Story. Er ist auch ein Charakter, den man entwickelt, wenn man nicht weiss, scheisse, wie kommen die Helden jetzt aus dieser Story heraus, ähm ... wie mache ich weiter? Du bist eigentlich der professionellste Moderator, den ich je gesehen habe. Mitten im Reden kriegst du eine Mail, pausierst, löscht sie und macht es dann weiter. Ich habe sie in den Papierkopf geschoben und habe aber schon Mute gedrückt, damit es nicht wieder versteht. Aber es ist so ein Charakter, den man erfindet, einfach aus Not, aber man nicht weiss, wie kriegt man die Leute jetzt wieder aus der Schlinge raus. Ja, ja, es ist ja so, also Filme sind ja wahnsinnig gut durchdacht, ne, und jeder Satz, jede Figur dient irgendeinem Zweck, bringt die Geschichte voran, bringt irgendwie die emotionalen Themen irgendwie weiter. Verkörpert irgendwie eine bestimmte Denkweise. Ja, genau, es bezieht irgendwo Positionen und mit denen kann sich der Zuschauer identifizieren und sagen, ah, die Position verstehe ich. Aber es gibt manchmal auch so Figuren, die genau das überhaupt nicht tun, die einfach, also zum Beispiel. Dutter Binks, wir sind nur in einem Kosmos gerade. Ja, ja, genug, aber zum Beispiel, wenn man mal einen Film drehen würde, wo Figuren vorkommen, die eigentlich nicht vorkommen sollten. Irgendwie so der minderbemittelte Bruder Lenny von dem Helden, der einfach mitkommt auf die Heldenreise, aber den man eigentlich nicht so wirklich braucht und der eigentlich keine Stimmung hat und auch wo der Regisseur irgendwann am Set sagt, ja, was auf Lenny, eigentlich… Ganz kurz, warum bambe dich nochmal, was genau ist seine Funktion? Was genau warst du denn nochmal dabei so, also wirklich, wenn am Ende der Held an der Klippe hängt und den Bösewicht gerade an der Hand packt und Lenny steht daneben mit seinem Smartphone und lacht und macht ein Selfie. Und man guckt sich Katzen wieder und macht ein Selfie. Dann denkst du einfach, wer genau war das nochmal, ganz genau? Ganz kurz, warum stehst du jetzt genau da an der Schlüsselszene? Ja. Ja, ich glaube auch, dass manchmal das so gefallen, die Regisseure oder Drehbuchautoren irgendwelchen Freunden tun. Irgendwie beim Pokern irgendwie alles verloren. Ja gut, komm, ich baue dich einen Film an. Ich baue dich einen Film ein, okay, gut, du bist Lenny und machst ein Selfie. Oder halt irgendwie Szenen, die vergessen wurden, rauszuschneiden. Einfach man hat irgendwie gross vor dem grossen Endkampf noch eine Szene, wo der Held sich über eine Zeitung kauft oder so. Oder nach dem grossen Kampf, wo er schon lange tot war eigentlich. Kauf sich nur eine Zeitung. Und der hat sich gesagt, Moment mal. Und am Ende wird es von allen Kritikern so als Super-Coup gefeiert. Ja genau, war ein Fehler. War ein schnittschlussfehler. Wahnsinnig innovative erzählweise nicht, es hat einfach nur ein Fehler. Ich glaube auch beip Fiction, es war einfach nur ein Schnittfehler, die haben irgendwann aus Versehen die Chronologie durcheinander gebracht und hatten einfach keinen Bock mehr, das nochmal neu zu sortieren, die haben einfach so das Projekt in das Schnittprogramm geladen und so gelassen. Ja genau, die haben auch genau in der Reihenfolge gedreht. Und es war einfach so, bis in fünf Minuten musste der Film raus, ah, bist du fertig? Ja, fuck it. Ja, guckt es euch mal an. Und dann ist Booster umgekippt, hat die Tastatur geschrottet. Booster hat den Film besser gemacht. Aber Booster hat den Film gerettet. Im Endeffekt tatsächlich hat Booster. Booster, Booster Energy Drink. Booster hat den Film tatsächlich. Booster hat den Film. Booster hat den Film. Einfach so 18 Minuten Pause. So ein Gag und dann 18 Minuten Pause. Hört ihr das? Das war John Cages vier Minuten dreiein dreissig. Ganz kurz für die Hörer, das ist wirklich spannend. John Cage ist ein Musiker, ein Künstler, der ganz tolle Ideen immer hat. Und zwar hat er, das ist Nerven so krass. Stimperhafteste Zusammenfassung des Lebens eines Künstlers. Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart, der hatte immer relativ gute Ideen. Ja, ich glaube auch, dass der nicht so gute Ideen hatte. Mit ganz guten Ideen. Also, ach man, ich bin wie so ein ADHS-Kind, jetzt fällt mir was zu Mozart ein. Ich habe echt, Mozart hat zum Beispiel mal ein Lied gehabt, muss ich kurz sagen, leckt mich im Arsch heisst es. Das war der Punk der damaligen Zeit, also ganz kurz, das stimmt wirklich. Jedenfalls John Cage. Auch so ein TV-Total-Nippel später dann. Back to John Cage. John Cage ist jemand, der hatte ganz interessante Ansätze, um an Musik zu gehen, hat auch ganz neue Ansätze und einmal hat er und der beste Gag des Podcast-O-Bus geht an R2D2! Jedenfalls hat er ein Stück, das heißt vier Minuten dreindreissig, wird mit Orchester inszeniert und dann kommt er, er ist der Dirigent, kommt nach vorne, fängt an anzuzählen. Ein ganzes Orchester hat vorher die Instrumente gestimmt, muss man sich vorstellen, alle in Erwartungshaltung, oh, John Cage präsentiert sein neues Stück, vier Minuten 33, was ist es, klingt spannend, er zählt an, er zählt an und es passiert nichts. Niemand spielt 4 Minuten 33 lang, genau, spielt niemand. Der Dirigent dirigiert aber trotzdem, er dirigiert die Pausen, 4 Minuten 33 lang passiert nichts und er blättert auch sogar die Notenblätter um und alle, und alle, irgendwann kippt auch die Stimmung des Publikums so langsam, wenn nichts mehr passiert.
Und was viele jetzt nicht sehen, Florentin ist der schlechteste Kurmoderator, er zeigt mir die ganze Zeit an, dass ich die Geschichte bitte zum Ende bringen soll.
Weißt du was, fick dich.
Aber die viel interessante Geschichte finde ich ja, das Hummeln.
Das ist nicht interessant.
Du hattest doch, äh...
Du warst doch mal... Du hattest doch, äh...
Du warst doch mal... Nee, du hattest doch ein Abenteuer mit der Polizei letztens.
Das war auch die Stimper, das ist eine Anmoderation irgendeiner Geschichte.
Du warst doch neulich abends mal weg. Wo warst du, hm? Erzähl doch mal, wer hätte dich denn gefragt? Niemand?
Du warst gar nicht mehr vor.
Du hattest doch letztens ein Erlebnis, oder?
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Dir ist doch letztens was passiert, erzähl doch mal.
Mich hat auf der Arbeit die Polizei angerufen, plötzlich, und ich dachte, ach du Scheiße, ist es ein Scherzanruf. Das ist Punk. Erstmal habe ich gelacht, um wirklich cool zu wirken. Wenn jemand sagt, ja hallo, hier ist die Polizei in Köln, dann sagt man den… Erstmal laut lachen, erst mal drei Minuten lang laut lachen und schlauen. Erstmal muss man davon ausgehen, ist es Marko-Phono, diese Scherzanrufseite, ist es was anderes, will ich mir verarschen, erst mal musst du cool rüberkommen und so tun, als klar, du weißt, dass jemand dich verarscht, du musst aber gleichzeitig auch so tun, du musst aber gleichzeitig auch so führer rüberkommen, dass wenn wirklich die Polizei dran ist, du nicht der völlige Idiot bist. Du musst zweigleisig fahren. Ja, na do, ist der Stefan, ist der Stefan Tietze, ja, ist korrekt, habe ich korrekt gesagt, das würde ich auch so Kumpel, die Scherz anruf machen, würde ich aber auch zur Polizei sagen, ist korrekt. Dann, und dann hat er gesagt, ja, das ist so, an ihrem Auto hat sich ein Lkw festgefahren. Da dachte ich mir, okay, das Scherz anruf wäre ein bisschen crazy. An ihrem Auto hat sich ein Lkw festgefahren, der kommt da nicht raus, sie müssten das wegfahren, sind die in der Nähe. Da dachte ich mir schon, okay, es ist wirklich die Polizei, weil niemand würde sowas als Herz anrufen machen, das ist ja, also niemand denkt so eine Geschichte aus. Und dann war es so, dass sich einen Lkw, ich habe auch sehr blöd geparkt, muss man sagen, aber der Polizist hat betont, dass es nie an mir lag, dass er sich festgefahren hat. Also er hat gesagt, er weiss, dass es ihr wichtig ist, dass man ihn parken kann. Natürlich parken Sie richtig, so als ob ich schon tausendmal irgendwie angerufen habe und gefragt habe, parken, parke ich richtig, so hat er gesagt. Natürlich, es ist nicht Ihr Problem, hey, hören Sie auf zu weinen, es ist nicht Ihr Problem. Und dann, ich sag mal, puh, Gott sei Dank, da hat sich aber wirklich ein Lkw dann so festgefahren. Das war eine Kurve, ich habe so eine L-förmige Einbahnstrassenkurve geparkt und es ist schon verständlich, dass sich da jemanden festfahren kann. Sind Sie bildlich für dein Leben? Ich bin in der L-förmigen Einbahnstrasse. Ich glaube, das ist auch der Titel einer Autobiografie, oder? Die L-Form, eine Einbahnstrasse. In der L-förmigen Einbahnstrasse geparkt. Und weiter bitte? Und das Ende der Geschichte ist dann, dass ich nicht kommen musste, weil sie den Lkw so wegfahren konnten. Aber finde ich ganz gut, diesen positiven Polizisten, immer versucht, nur was Positives zu sagen. Ja, sie haben vier Leute ermordet, aber sie haben sehr gut getroffen. Das habe ich selten gesehen. Fünf Schüsse, vier Tote.
Genau ins Herz, genau ins Herz, einmal genau im Kopf, das geht immer weg.
Applaudiert.
Aber es ist aber auch so, immer wenn ich die Polizei sehe, wenn ich auf der Autobahn fahre oder normal über die Strasse gehe,
ich habe immer Angst, dass ich irgendwas falsch mache, wenn ich die Polizei sehe.
Man hat immer das Gefühl, man muss sich selber kontrollieren und gucken, was man gerade falsch macht.
Ob man was falsch macht.
Ja, wir haben heute mal die Top 5 aufgestellt.
Nee, ganz kurz. Hast du gute Geschichten mit der Polizei?
Überhaupt nicht. Ich bin komplett Gesetzeskreuer.
Ich habe noch eine Geschichte. Ich wurde fast festgenommen.
Ja, dann hau rein.
Ich bin aber in eine rote Ampel gegangen.
Ich pointe Farah.
Ich komme gleich wieder.
Ich wurde, nee, es war so, ich bin über eine Ampel gegangen und über eine rote, und dann waren auch Kinder, da dachte ich mir, ja gut, was wird das nicht tun, habe ich trotzdem gemacht.
Dann ist die Polizei hinter mir gerannt, ich mache es jetzt ein bisschen schneller, damit es schnell vorbei ist.
Weil die auch schnell gerannt haben, weil es einen ungeduldigen Blitz ist.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Überhaupt nicht, ich habe die Geschichte nur schon achtmal gehört, aber hau rein.
Und dann war ich aber relativ schnell bei mir zu Hause, bin durch die Wohnung gegangen, aber hinter mir, das habe ich halt nicht gemerkt, weil ich Kopfhörer im Ohr hatte, ist sehr schnell die Polizei hinter mir hergerannt, die sind halt mit blauen Lichtern um die Ecke gefahren, sind ausgestiegen, um mir hinterher zu spriten, weil die gesehen haben, dass ich schon mein Haus erreicht habe, wollten mir aber unbedingt noch die fünf Euro wegnehmen, da haben die sich in die Tür reingeschmissen, die gerade so am Zufallen war, er hat sich eine Polizistin reingeschmissen, ich völlig verwirrt, völlig Hände hochgerissen, was wollen Sie, was wollen Sie, ganz kurz, Sie sind über Rot gegangen, ich brauch fünf Euro von Ihnen, so, das war die Pointe. Aber das finde ich aber auch gut, wenn du den besten Polizeifluchtskandal aller Zeiten begangen hättest, ohne es zu merken. Ohne es zu merken. Genauso wie du aus dem Gefängnisausbrichst, ohne es zu merken. Ja, ich habe nur einen Spaziergang gemacht, ich war bei Burger King, sorry Leute, tut mir echt leid, aber ich habe sie gesehen, da war kein Schild. Den grössten Mord unwissend begehen. Ich wusste nicht, dass der Diabetiker ist. Halloween, dass die Kinder an Halloween Diabetiker sind. Wenn man den Kontext nachreicht, wenn man merkt, der Gag kommt nicht. Wenn der Kontext zur Pointe wird. Ui, das ist doch ein schönes T-Shirt. Die grossen fünf, du wolltest jetzt die grossen fünf machen.
Die grossen fünf Tipps, wie man sich nicht in Gespräche einklingt.
Mit Florentin Will.
Platz eins.
Platz eins an.
Man wird immer schlechter, so die antiklimaktischen.
Jeder kennt die Situation, deine coolen Freunde unterhalten sich gerade über irgendwas.
Hey, habt ihr schon das neue Bibis Beauty Palace Video gesehen?
Habt ihr schon den neuen Bibiblogsbergs Kanal mitbekommen?
Irgendwas und man versucht selber in das Gespräch mit reinzukommen, aber...
Habt ihr schon die neue Folge, die Maybrit Illner geguckt, hat das jemals jemand gesagt?
Habt ihr schon die neue Apotheken Rundschau gelesen, ja?
Habt ihr schon die neue Staffel von Alarm für Cobra 11?
Alarm für... Hey, du kannst doch nicht in meine Porten rein! Das sind acht Millionen Serien!
Das sind die Pausen, in die ich... Das würde doch lustig sein!
Das ist doch keine Pause, Mensch! Das sind die Pausen, die ich nachher rausschneide! Ganz kurz, du hast ja in meine Pointe reingesprochen. Das sind die No-Go's. Die großen fünf Podcast-No-Go's. Ja, okay, okay. Machen wir die fünf Podcast-No-Go's von mir aus. Kein Problem. Wir haben sogar die besten zehn Podcast-No-Go's. Wir können die besten zwanzig machen von mir aus. Die haben wir schon in diesem Podcast versteckt. Wer sie findet, kriegt ein T-Shirt von Florian Will geschenkt. Wir müssen jetzt nur noch die Timecodes angeben. Schreibt uns die Timecodes der zehn grössten Podcastsünden dieses Podcasts in die Kommentare bei Watcher oder bei Oma. Wer das herausfindet, kriegt ein T-Shirt, ein bereits getragenes T-Shirt von Florian Will geschenkt. Von uns beiden,, wir beide getragen haben. Okay. Alles klar. Wieder Freunde? Komm. Tut mir leid, dass ich nichts falsch gemacht habe. Tut mir leid, dass ich in deine Pointe reingeredet habe. Wir sollten auch gerne einen Top... Ganz kurz, wir sollten das auch... Nimmst du wieder auf? Ich nehme den ganzen Tag auf. Wir sollten das nicht Top 5 nennen. Es gibt schon viele Top 5. Ja, wir sollen es dann nennen.
Top 4. Wir sparen uns wenige Arbeit, haben Namen verändert, super gut.
So, jetzt kommt unsere Rubrik, eine unzusammenhängende Liste von Dingen, die ihr in gewissen Situationen tun solltet.
Und die es in keinem anderen Podcast gibt.
Die es in keinem anderen Podcast gibt, und zwar heute mit den Themen, wie ihr euch am...
Wie ihr euch auf gar keinen Fall in ein Gespräch einklinken könnt.
Platz 5 bei Florentin.
Ich bin halt ein bisschen neben der Spur, es tut mir leid.
Warum, was heute Morgen passiert?
Du bist ins Büro gekommen.
Ich bin eben nicht ins Büro gekommen, es wird zugesperrt.
Also, die Top 5 Ideen, wie ihr euch in ein Gespräch einklinken wollt.
Auf Platz 5 bei mir, Magazine. Niemals über Magazine reden, die Leute lesen keine Magazine mehr. Letztens hatte ich mir tatsächlich, also, muss ich zu weit ausholen. Okay, bei mir auf Platz 5 nichts sagen. Wenn man nichts sagt, kommt man nicht ins Gespräch. Ist selbsterklärend, ich denke, das schafft ja auch alleine. Florentin Blass 4. Ja, aber kennst du so Leute, denen auf Partys die schüchterne Leute versuchen, ins Gespräch einzubauen, die sagen, Stefan, du hast ja dazu noch gar nichts gesagt. Wo ich mir denke, äh, hallo, brauchst du einen Busser oder was? Ist doch gemein, um schüchterne Leute ins Gespräch zu holen. Ja. Hör mal, Sven, du hast heute noch gar nichts gesagt. Ja. Es hilft, es hilft aber auch nicht. Ja, vor allem, das ist die schlechtest mögliche Einleitung. Was soll er sagen? Du hast noch nichts gesagt. Was soll er soll er sagen? Habe ich vergessen. Ja, das weiss die schüchterne Person sehr gut, dass sie nichts gesagt hat, weil das ist ihr konstantes Problem. Das ist genauso, wie wenn man jemandem sagt, der ein rotes Gesicht hat, so, du hast ja ein ganz rotes Gesicht, was ist ein Losa? Das ist genau das gleiche, das stimmt, das hast du recht, das ist beides sehr schlimm. Es ist wirklich beides sehr schlimm. Platz 5 ist bei mir jedenfalls nichts sagen, also wenn man nichts sagt, kommt man auch nicht ins Gespräch. Aber man darf auch Leute nicht ins Gespräch holen. Also die Intention dahinter ist natürlich... Auch als Podcaster nicht. Man sollte versuchen, den anderen nicht ins Gespräch zu holen. Das ist der Sinn. Die Intention dahinter ist natürlich edel... Du hast Podcasten soeben durchgespielt, glaube ich. Die Intention dahinter ist natürlich edel, dass man sagt, man möchte schüchende Leute ins Gespräch involvieren. Aber es klappt erstens nicht und zweitens … Platz vier bei mir, schlechte Themen. Mit dem Wetter zum Beispiel kann man niemanden begeistern, oder über Tod. Tod zum Beispiel ist kein gutes Thema, um in ein Gespräch zu kommen, gerade wenn es … auch auf einer Beerdigung. Auf einem Beerdigungsthema Tod ist ein sehr gutes Thema, um in ein Gespräch zu kommen, sonst eher unpassend. Florentin mit seiner Nummer vier. Nummer vier, Dinge wiederholen. Es gibt immer Leute, die im Gespräch sind und einfach Dinge wiederholen, die andere Leute sagen. So, ey, letzten Samstag war ich aber echt beim Fluss und hab mir einen Stein geholt und dann die andere Person so, am Samstag, ja. Ich auch. Gucken alle die Personen an und so, ja. Ja, ja. Vor allem wenn man eine volle wehre Story erzählt. Ja, mir ist ein Baum auf den Kopf gefallen, in dem war ein Biber. Und dann ist ein Boot gekommen und hat ein Biber mitgenommen. Und dann sind sie weggefahren, dann kam die Biber-Polizei. Und wenn der andere dann sagt, ja, das ist mir auch passiert. Das ist mir auch passiert. Nein. Nummer drei bei mir ist,achen. Bei mir ist auch lachen. Nummer drei ist lachen bei mir tatsächlich. Ich habe es just made up, just made it up. Also lachen, in ein Gespräch zu kommen, ohne wirklich was beizutragen, ist nicht gut. Ich habe noch keinen Grund, dafür kamen die Don't drink and podcast. Don't boost and podcast. Entschuldigung, wir haben uns gerade einen anderen lustigen Podcast angehört. Also Nummer drei bei mir ist Lachen. Lachen kommt man einfach nicht in Gespräche. Dabei ist es ein Problem, weil wir eine Top-Fünf darüber machen, über die Situation, die wir haben. Dass wir das Problem haben, dass wir nicht ins Gespräch kommen und eine Top-5 darüber machen, wie man es nicht machen sollte und das haben wir offensichtlich keine Kompetenz dafür. Auf Platz zwei, bei dir? Etwas runterwerfen. Also das versucht man ja oft, oft ist ja tatsächlich in Gespräche kommen ein physischer Akt, ja, also du musst irgendwie in den Gesprächskreis reinkommen. Bei mir ist auch ganz kurz ein physischer Takt, anfassen, Leute anfassen und so versuchen, ins Gespräch zu kommen.
Ist aber ungefähr das gleiche.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel man kennt den klassischen Kreis, in dem irgendwie Leute reden.
Und in dem ich drin bin in allen Kreisen und Breakdancer.
Ich bin in der Mitte.
Ich bin in der Mitte Breakdancer.
Genau. Und dann irgendwie die Strategie ist, man wirft irgendwas runter, irgendwie einen Stein, einen kleinen Stein, irgendwie ein Stimpel, Papier, ein Baby, ein Kind, eine Gurke, irgendwas, was man gerade parat hat. Und dann muss man man so sich, oh Entschuldigung, kann ich ganz kurz durch? Kann ich ganz kurz Opossum aufholen? Kann ich ganz kurz meine Maus aufheben? Mein Furby, mein Furby. Kann ich ganz kurz meinen Tamagotchi aufheben? Alle meine Witze sind nur Variationen. Ja, Variationen von Tamagotchis oder Furbys auch. Dann hebt man den auf und dann ist man physisch zumindest schon mal im Kreis und kann dann sagen, Leute, verrücktes Football-Spiel gestern, oder? Und dann so was weiter. Und dann weiter. Wo du auch gerade sagst, wenn du Football sagst, denke ich immer, du hast diesen Witz gerade aus dem amerikanischen Podcast geklaut. Der gesamte Podcast ist aus dem Podcast geklaut. Weißt du, was mir aufgefallen ist? Du fängst ja oft an, zu erzählen, dass wir so eine Sound-CD aufnehmen wollen, wo wir alle Sounds drin gemacht haben und die selber auf On-Air aufnehmen. Also wir wollen Geld damit verdienen, dass wir Sound-Effekte produzieren, die wir dann verkaufen. Zum Beispiel der Doppler-Effekt. So war's.
Ja.
So, dann hab ich, dann habst du mir ein paar Podcasts genannt, die gut sind, die ich mir anhören kann.
Und es waren tausend Podcasts zur Auswahl.
Und in jedem einzelnen Podcast kommt dieser Gag vor.
Tausend Podcasts waren zur Auswahl.
A, tausend Sendungen.
Jeder dieser Podcast, der gibt's schon jahrelang.
Ich hör in eine zufällig random rein.
Es war noch niemals irgendwie die erste, von einem, willkürlich die 25. Folge oder so, in Minute drei. Und in Minute drei der Gag ist dann, ja, hey, wie läuft es eigentlich mit deiner Aufnahme-CD, wo wir alle Songs, wo wir alle Sounds aufnehmen. Welcher Podcast ist das? Comedy Bang Bang. Willke und ich eine Folge, ich gehe jetzt eine Minute, ich höre das gerade erst, fange mich an einzuhören und der erste Gag, den die im Laufe des Podcasts machen, war diese scheisse CD, von der du je immer redest. Und dann, was ist noch alles geklaut? Unsere Studio-Deko, unsere Mikros. Ja, die Studio-Deko ist geklaut. Was ist noch von uns, Florence? Die Studio-Deko ist gek Florenzi? Ich habe null Vertrauen mehr in dich.
Die Studiodeco ist auf Starlight Express geklaut, tut mir leid.
Was, das gibt's schon? Ich glaube, es wäre mega innovativ, dass wir mit Pyrotechnik auf Rollschuhen hier rumlaufen.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Und diese albernen Kostüme, ich dachte, das wäre innovativ.
Nein, das ist überhaupt nicht innovativ.
Und sieht doch auch niemand. Warum haben wir denn diese Kostüme an?
Es ist aber echt lame, dass du mich jetzt hier komplett einfach vorführst.
Das hast du schon so aufgemacht bei mir. Das entwickelt sich jetzt gleich jetzt in dem Handfesten Streit, mein Lieber.
Wir haben jetzt hier gleich ein richtiges Problem, mein junger Mann.
Wir kriegen hier gleich ein richtiges Problem.
Das sind so Sätze, die Eltern zu ihren Kindern sagen, auf Platz fünf oder auf Platz vier.
Da legt das weg.
Da ab Platz drei, der Top fünf, der besten Top dreist, die wir jemals versaut haben. Stefan Witze. Es fühlt sich gerade echt an wie Rockbottom. Wir sind hier in so einem schäbigen Studio, nebenan nimmt irgendeine schlechte Studentenband, irgendwie schlechte Songs auf. Die Decke bricht fast durch, die Decke bricht fast durch, wir haben irgendwelche billigen Energydrinks. Hey, ganz kurz, das nimmst du zurück. Es ist ein Boosted Energydrink. Ich habe drei Jahre keinen fucking... Das ist doch scheiße hier, was ist das für eine fangen Geschmacksache, so Greengrass. Ich habe seit drei Jahren keinen Energydrink mehr getrunken. Probier mal bitte die andere, probier mal Thunderstorm. Ich will die andere Dose jetzt nicht aufmachen, weil das Zeug echt ätzend ist. Das ist echt... Nee, ich trinke da nicht aus deinem Aids-verseuchten Scheiss da. Alter, hattest du mal einen Tiefpunkt? Tatsächlich in deinem Leben hattest du mal wirklich einen Punkt. Also du bist noch relativ jung und du hast, glaube ich, jetzt ein relativ gutes Leben geführt bis dahin. Du hast einen guten Job bekommen, deinen Traumjob mehr oder weniger. Traumjob. Relativ vom Start ab. Star Wars. Mir geht es ähnlich. Ich glaube, das hängt auch damit zu tun, dass wir relativ wenig zu erzählen haben. Also es ist tatsächlich so, wenn man sich andere Podcasts anhört, was andere Leute schon für einen Scheiss durchgemacht haben. Die haben auch noch so Sauve-Stories zu erzählen und die haben aber auch dann so ein Leben hinter sich, wo sie ganz viel gemacht haben, schauen und sehr viel gescheitert sind und so. Das sind auch Comedians, sie sind oft sehr tragische Persönlichkeiten, die schon sehr viel Scheisse getreten sind in ihrem Leben und die haben noch dementsprechend zu viel zu erzählen, die haben wir nicht. Nee, aber wir sind ja auch tatsächlich komplette Langweiler, also ja beide. Also tatsächlich, wie sieht für dich ein schöner Abend aus? Also wenn du sagst, das war echt ein schöner Abend, wie sieht das für dich aus? Ich sitze zu Hause und gucke mir was auf Netflix an und wenn ich Glück habe, kommt mein Essen pünktlich, sonst drehe ich durch. Aber auch nicht wirklich, dass es interessant wäre zu erzählen, sondern ich reg mich auf, sag mal kurz, ach Mensch, es ist zu spät gekommen. Das sind so das emotionale Highlight. Aber geht mir ganz genauso. Ein schöner Abend ist für mich, wo ich um 20 Uhr da sitze und sage, Alter, ich habe jetzt sechs Stunden lang einfach Zeit. Ich glaube, als Comedy-Typ ist man eigentlich, kann man das Charakter nicht beschreiben, sagen, dass man eher der Einzelgänger ist? Ja, kann man. Also es gibt ja so die Theorien, dass man, sag ich mal, humoristisches Geschick aus, sag ich mal, einer gewissen Verletzbarkeit generiert, dass man halt mit Humor viele Dinge auf Abstand halten kann und alles irgendwie relativiert und einfach sagen kann, man macht sich drüber lustig und muss sich nicht tatsächlich damit beschäftigen. Es ist sowieso ein Wegstoßen von sich, weil man irgendwie immer die Möglichkeit hat, es irgendwie in einem anderen Kontext zu sehen. Deswegen hat man immer die Möglichkeit, irgendwie Dinge nicht ernst nehmen zu müssen. Humor ist auch immer Distanz. Also du kannst nicht über Dinge lachen, wenn die sich emotional berühren. Und du kannst aber im Gegenzug auch emotional Dinge auf Abstand halten, indem du über sie lachst, weil dann schaffst du die Distanz, die du eigentlich auch verbrauchst. Das ist auch so eine Win-Win-Situation. Du lernst sehr gut, Dinge auf Abstand zu halten. Wirst halt nur zum Soziopath. Ja, natürlich. Wenn du dann mal Dinge nicht auf Abstand halten möchtest, dann fällt es dir vielleicht schwer, weil du halt nicht die... Es fällt halt wie so ein Stein auf dich herab, den du lange, lange Zeit mit der Macht über dir, mit der Macht des Comedys, das ist die beste Metapher, die ich jemals... Und das haben ein paar Leute gehört. Wenn man gute Dinge erzählt und es hören viele Leute, immer so ein Jackpot. JaMoment. Yes! Und irgendwann fällt diese Macht halt, weil du halt irgendwie wirklich gratflitzbar bist, auf dich herab umso härter und dann wirst du hart getroffen. Ja und vor allem, du hast auch nicht die richtigen Werkzeuge, um mit jemandem klar zu kommen, der nah an dich rankommt. Also ich vergleiche das gerne mit Pfeil und Bogen. Als Comedian bist du gut mit Pfeil und Bogen, du kannst sehr gut Dinge bearbeiten, die weit weg sind, aber sobald jemand nah an dich rankommt, hast du nicht die Waffen, um damit tatsächlich umzugehen. Wenn ich jetzt nah zu dir rankomme und frage, wie sieht es in deinem Liebesleben gerade aus? Ja, dann stehe ich mit Waffenluster, ja, mich entwaffnet, ja, kann ich nicht drüber reden. Das stimmt nicht, ich könnte über mein Liebesleben distanziert sprechen, also indem ich mich entweder darüber lustig mache oder indem ich
irgendwie eine analytische Position einnehme und das versuche zu analysieren. Aber wenn ich dann aber so einen Markus-Lanz-Typ dann raushängen lasse und sage, nee, nee, komm, lass mal den Humor jetzt beiseite, sag mal wirklich, wie siehst du wirklich bei dir aus? Und irgendwann hast du keine Chance mehr und es ist leer und der trifft genau bei dir rein, in die Seele. Aber ich glaube, dass Menschen tatsächlich so aufgebaut sind.
Also wenn du mich fragen würdest, wie ist für dich ein Mensch aufgebaut, würde ich die Metapher des Donuts wählen. Also viele Leute denken ja immer so, sie sind... Ich bin donutförmig. Genau, donutförmig. Du bist, was du isst. Ich habe einen birnenförmigen Körper, aber ich bin in der Willigkeit Donut. In einem Donut drinsteckst du. Donut mit Birnenfüllung ist die perfekte menschliche Analogie. Viele Leute denken ja, wenn ich in der Öffentlichkeit bin, dann trage ich irgendwie eine Maske, aber eigentlich bin ich jemand ganz anderes, in meinem tiefsten Inneren bin ich eigentlich so, keine Ahnung, ich helfe jetzt dem nicht, aber eigentlich bin ich schon sehr hilfsbedürftig. Immer so diese Entscheidung zwischen, also ich glaube, die meisten Menschen haben so ein Persönlichkeitsmodell von so einer Nuss, die eine Schale hat, aber die einen Kern hat. Und bei mir ist es genau das Gegenteil, ein Donut ist in der Mitte leer, es gibt nur die Schale. Das heißt, wenn die Leute dich näher kennenlernen, stossen sie auf die langweiligste Person ever. Nein, nein, nein, da ist gar keine Person, es ist leere, man besteht nur aus Maske. Die Maske ist realer. Du bist nur die Rolle. Ja, genau. Du bist nur der Rolle. Du bist nur dem Rahmen, den du dir gebaut hast. Genau, man ist nur der Rahmen. Es gibt keinen Inhalt. Warst du es immer schon? Ich glaube, jeder Mensch ist so. Ich glaube, jeder Mensch ist in einer gewissen Weise so. Aber machst du dir manchmal Gedanken, warum bin ich jetzt in einer Comedy gelandet? Warum beispielsweise... Ja, natürlich. Stellst du diese Frage häufiger? Also ich mir zum Beispiel sehr oft. Ja. Da frage ich mich, warum ist das so gelaufen? Ich versuche immer eine Erklärung meiner Vergangenheit zu finden, aber es ist nicht so einfach. Nee, es ist nicht so einfach. Aber ich glaube, also wenn du dir einen Donut anschaust, wenn ich jetzt einen Comic über einen Donut... Ich finde es toll, wie du diese Mischaufferstoff ziehst. Wenn ich einen Comic über einen Donut schreiben würde, dann würde ich sagen, der Donut hat ein Problem, damit er sein Loch hat. Das ist so das Problem vom Donut. So er geht durch den Alltag und denkt sich, ich habe ein Loch eigentlich... Moment, ganz kurz, aber er charakterisiert sich ja selber durch dieses Loch. Ja, aber nee, das wäre der Donut am Ende der Geschichte. Der Anfangsdonut, der ein Problem hat, der nicht mit sich selbst als Person klarkommt, der beschwert sich über sein Loch, am Ende steht dann der Wandel durch das ganze Abenteuer, er trifft andere Verbündete und kämpft gegen Monster und am Ende akzeptiert er sich so wie er ist. Aber ich glaube... Es ist ein komischer Donut, von dem wir da sprechen. Es ist ein sehr spezieller Donut. Er kämpft gegen Orks. Dienfüllung ist tatsächlich da schon recht weit weg. Aber tatsächlich, also wenn du das immer auf die Menschenmetapher überträgst, glaube ich, dass viele Menschen diese Lehre in sich spüren und versuchen, sie durch irgendwas zu ersetzen. Dass sie sagen, eigentlich bin ich ein sehr tiefgründiger, spiritueller Mensch, ich habe einen tiefen inneren Kerne. Also diese Idee der Seelen ist das inneren Kerne. Vielleicht ist das eine Art Schauspieler. Ich glaube, das ist auch bei Schauspielern so, die dann halt immer, ich glaube, die sind da auch so eine Art Loch und immer so, also man nimmt so Rollen an. Ja, genau. Aber ich glaube, die Rolle ist echter als du selbst. Die Maske ist realer als du selbst. Du bist die Maske, es gibt nichts darunter. Und das ist eigentlich der wahre Weg zur Selbsterkenntnis, meiner Meinung nach, wenn man das mehr oder weniger akzeptiert, dass es eigentlich nichts anderes gibt. Weil bei vielen Leuten ist es ja so, ja, eigentlich bin ich ja jemand ganz anderes und wenn ich nach Hause komme, dann nehme ich meine Maske ab und dann sage ich, nee, du hast nur eine andere Maske auf. Du bist halt wie so ein Donut, der sich in alle Richtungen abschirmen kann, sehr kreisförmig. Aber du redest jetzt nur von Comedien, du redest nur von Comedien und nicht von normalen Menschen. Ich würde sagen, Comedien sind da in der Hinsicht extremer, in gewisser Weise extremer vielleicht, beziehungsweise die haben das, glaube ich, eher verstanden. Die sind eher zynisch, dass sie sagen, so eigentlich kann man sich nur darüber lustig machen oder eigentlich ist Humor eine gute Möglichkeit, weil im Endeffekt gibt es überhaupt nichts zu kaschieren. Ich habe immer gelesen, dass Comedians, speziell Comedians, sehr bipolare Persönlichkeiten haben oder oft eine bipolare Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Heisst, dass sie entweder Dinge sehr, sehr, sehr schnell sehr glücklich macht oder auf der anderen Seite, dass sie sehr schnell sehr depressiv sind.
Das ist bei mir tatsächlich das genaue Gegenteil.
Dass sie dazwischen nicht viel kennen.
Ja. Aber würdest du dir eher ein Leben wünschen, dass…
Ist es bei dir so, ganz kurz.
Nee, ich glaube, bei mir ist es eher das Gegenteil.
Was ist das Gegenteil davon?
Dass ich, sag ich mal, die ganz krassen Ausschwüne nicht habe, aber dafür es auch nicht stark nach unten geht. Also wenn du die Entscheidung hättest, würdest du lieber ein Leben haben, wo die Ausschläge stark nach oben gehen, aber auch stark nach unten, oder würdest du eher ein gemässiges Leben haben, wo du nie wirklich leidest, aber auch nie wirklich richtig glücklich bist? Lieber das Gemässigte. Aber ich glaube, es wird schon auf mich zutreffen. Also vielleicht habe ich sowas. Ja, aber das ist die Frage. Sind Psychologen unter euch? Ich glaube, ich bin entweder sehr schnell, ich bin sehr schnell sehr niedergeschlagen, aber dann auf der anderen Seite, und das ist häufiger so glücklicherweise, sehr schnell sehr euphorisch und kann über sehr viele Dinge sehr lachen. Und das ist, glaube ich, so. Vielleicht hat man das. Nein, also ich glaube, bei mir ist es eher anders, weil du auch diese ganz tiefen Täler mit Kumor ausgleichen kannst, weil du kannst dann sehr gut über dich lachen und du kannst dann sehr gut Witze drüber machen, wie du keine Freundin hast oder wie du immer versagst überall, kannst du sehr gut Witze drüber machen, wohingegen jemand anders wirklich eine depressive Verstimmung kommen würde und wirklich einfach traurig wäre, könntest du drüber lachen, du lachst über dich selbst, was eigentlich nur ein Weglaufen vor deinen eigentlichen Problemen ist, weil du es irgendwie kaschiert, natürlich ist es gut, es ist für deine psychische Gesundheit natürlich schon gut, weil du nie wirklich unten ankommst, aber es kann ja vielleicht manchmal auch positive Effekte haben, wenn du wirklich ganz unten ankommst, weil du, sag ich mal, die ganze Bandbreite der menschlichen Erfahrung auskosten kannst, wohingegen du als Zyniker, als gemässiger Typ halt immer nur in der Mitte irgendwie rumringst. Um es mit Platons Höhen gleich auszudrücken, Dunkelheit. Dunkelheit, ja, im Grunde Dunkelheit. Ja, aber das ist jetzt die Frage. Das war die philosophische Viertelstunde. Ja, aber tatsächlich ist, sag ich mal, also ich glaube, Leute mit Humor, also Humor ist ja, sag ich mal, eine gewisse Einstellung, dass du Dinge nicht nur so hinnimmst, wie sie sind, sondern sie analysierst. Du machst ja ständig Gedanken drüber. Nee, du hast ein normal funktionierendes Gehirn und du hast ein analysierendes Gehirn. Und das andere ist quasi so ein gewissermassen so ein Du-Selbst, der aus dir heraustritt und von oben herab auf dich guckst, mit der Distanz, die du halt brauchst. Ja. Ja, aber... Damit wäre alles gesagt. Naja gut, aber ich glaube, dass dieser Reflex der Analyse, glaube ich, kann auch zum Problem werden, weil du eine so mächtige Sprache, ein mächtiges Werkzeug entwickelt hast, mit deinen Problemen umzugehen, indem du sie analysierst, dass du gar keinen wirklichen Impuls mehr hast, sie zu ändern. Also wenn du so gut verstanden hast, warum dir gewisse Dinge nicht gelingen, dann hast du überhaupt keinen Anreiz dazu, sie zu verändern. Ich möchte dir ein ganz konkretes Beispiel dazu bringen. Und zwar gab es mal die Situation, dass ich in eine Frau verliebt war, mit der ich mich jede Woche getroffen habe. Das ist ja wirklich sehr intim jetzt. Aber nicht, ich möchte nur das andere Beispiel festmachen, mit der ich mich jede Woche getroffen habe, aber jetzt nicht in einem romantischen Kontext, sondern halt so als Freunde. Und wir haben uns jede Woche regelmässig getroffen und jede Woche habe ich mir aufs Neue vorgenommen, okay, jetzt gestehe ich hier meine grossen Gefühle, jetzt kommt das grosse romantische Happy End, jetzt geht's los. Und es gab immer die Situation, wo ich sie an ihrer Haustür verabschiedet habe und gesagt, ja, so bis nächste Woche hier und da. Und jedes Mal habe ich mir gedacht, komm, jetzt sag irgendwas, mach irgendwas, habe es aber nie gemacht. Und tatsächlich hatte ich dann immer einen relativ langen Heimweg und habe dann auf dem Heimweg immer nachgedacht, warum hat es nicht geklappt, warum kriege ich das nicht hin und hab diese ganze Situation analysiert. Und einmal hatte ich den erleuchtenden Moment, wo ich sogar noch, während ich vor ihr stand und die Möglichkeit hatte, schon angefangen habe, darüber nachzudenken, wie ich auf dem Nachhause gehen analysieren werde, warum es gerade nicht geklappt hat. Und ich habe mich so in dieser Situation wohlgefühlt, die Dinge zu analysieren, dass ich überhaupt nicht den Leidensdruck hatte, die Situation zu verändern. Und das war tatsächlich ein großes Problem, weil ich ein so gutes System entwickelt habe, mit diesem Leidensdruck umzugehen, dass er nicht stark genug werden konnte, weil ich so gut gegen ihn ankämpfen konnte. Das stimmt. Und deswegen konnte nie was passieren. Diese berühmte Friendzone. Ich wurde ... Okay, da hier ... Ach, das klingt jetzt gar nicht klar. Komm jetzt in die komplette Demo rein. Komm mal rein. Komm mal rein. Ganz gut. Hier sind Mitarbeiter. Komm mal kurz rein. Ach du Scheiße. Alter. Hey, kannst du mal kurz reinkommen? Wir nehmen gerade einen Podcast auf. Hast du was zu sagen? Hast du was zu sagen, Willi? Ja, komm rein, komm her. Du bist unser Gast.
Ach komm, kannst du uns eine Story erzählen?
Warst du mal in der Friendzone?
Nee.
Magst du einen Witz erzählen? Okay, das ist eine komplett andere Person.
Weißt du, wir fucking Nerds und einfach hier so kommt der Rockstar rein, so ne, keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Dann gib uns doch mal einen Tipp, wie kommt man aus der Friendzone raus?
Ich weiss gar nicht, was das ist, du musst es mir erklären.
Weißt du, was eine Friendzone ist? Wenn du mit einer Frau befreundet bist, mit der du aber eigentlich eine romantische Beziehung anfangen möchtest und es nicht schaffst, diesen Sprung zu wagen. Also erstmal nicht schaffen, Sprung wagen ist der Fehler, du musst den Sprung wagen und dann, wenn sie dann die Leier abzieht, dass sie sagt, ne, ich will nicht, dass ich ... Man geht automatisch davon aus, dass die Leier kommen. Ne, dass ich dich als Freund verliere und so, und das ist ja das Normale. Ja, du, ich mag dich total, aber ich will dich nicht als Freund verlieren und so, und das ist auch viel wichtiger und das kann man doch nicht kaputt machen und so. Da muss man einfach sagen, ja, pass auf. Da muss man sie direkt schlagen. Ja. Das müssen wir damit sagen. Du schein Schwein. Warte, jetzt kommt der interessante Teil, Stefan, pass aufs nicht. Also es gibt Gewalt gegen Frauen, finde ich generell super, aber vor allem Rohgewalt, also einen festen Schlag auf die Nase. Also das ist halt, ich mag diese Reaktion, dass keine Reaktion mehr kommt, verstehst du? Okay. Ja, okay. Das war das Lustigste, was jetzt in den letzten fünfzehn Minuten passiert ist. Fünfzig Minuten. Aber jetzt, okay, also was macht man dann? Und wenn dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wenn das alles geklärt ist. Wenn die Polizei, Krankenhaus, wenn all das passiert ist, Gerätsverfahren, Herr Anwalt, ja. Und man wieder irgendwie sagt, man kann wieder normal miteinander reden und sie dann wieder sagt, ja, aber ich will dich nicht als Freund verlieren und du bist im Psycho. Und als Gewalttäter, ja. Ich will dich nicht als Gewalttäter verlieren, ja. Ja, genau, das ist ja auch, also ich meine, das ist ja auch ein herber Verlust, wenn man einen Gewalttäter verliert. Da muss man ja einfach die kalte Schulter zeigen und sagen. Und dann? Und, also ne, im Sinne von Elbow. Elbow, also erst mal wieder verletzen ... Okay, okay, wir haben wieder ein Gerechtverfahren, wieder kann man das aufhören und dann ... Du hast sie fallen lassen und du machst sie klar. Du machst sie interessanter für sie, oder? Das ist doch der Punkt. Du machst sie interessanter, weil du sie abschießt. Genau, und dann irgendwann kommt sie, dann meldest du dich irgendwann oder dann fängt der Kontakt wieder an und denkst, okay, vielleicht ist ist was gezündet und dann machst du nochmal einen Move und dann sagst sie, nein, aber ich will dich als Freund nicht verlieren. Und ich meine, dann...
Was war denn...
Keine Lösung in Sicht!
Wir haben keine Lösung in Sicht, aber wir werden straftätig. Okay, danke, danke.
Aber ich muss aber Pizza bestellen.
Pizza bestellen.
Vielen Dank, mach's gut.
Ja, mach's gut, vielen Dank.
Das war der beste Tipp meines Lebens. Okay, wir brauchen mehr Gäste oder viel weniger Gäste. Sehr gut, also. Oh Gott, oh Mann. Ich glaube, ich habe gerade die letzten drei Minuten, ist das Leben an mir vorbei gerauscht und ich habe nicht so richtig verstanden, was gerade passiert ist. Aber naja, lass uns auch mal kommentieren.
Buster hat die gesamte Aufnahme ruiniert.
Ich weiß nicht, wir trinken nie mehr Buster.
Buster hat uns in die Emotionalität getrieben, Buster hat uns in das Philosophen getrieben.
Ich kann mich auf nichts konzentrieren. Ich sehe das Fenster, es ist offen und ich will zumachen, dann sehe ich dein Bildschirm flackert und ich will es anfassen.
Kann das sein, dass die ein bisschen hyperaktiv sind?
Ich habe mega ADHS.
Alter, was ist denn los, ey?
Ganz kurz, ich hatte mal die Situation, dass ich neun Stunden lang auf einen Zug warten musste, im Kölner Hauptbahnhof, und ich habe mich dazu entschlossen, auf den Zug zu warten und nicht irgendwie in ein Hotel zu gehen und zu schlafen, sondern einfach zu warten. Neun Stunden lang? Neun Stunden lang und habe mir tatsächlich, glaube ich, sechs Dosen Red Bull gekauft, habe mich ans Rheinufer gesetzt und dachte mir einfach, ich mache einfach die Nacht durch, fuck it, und höre einfach Musik und höre Podcast und laufe einfach durch die Nacht in Köln, warum nicht? Nach Stunde eins fällt einem auf, mein Handy hält neun Stunden lang nicht durch, ich halte neun Stunden lang nicht durch, mein Red Bull sollte ich nach der zweiten Dose vielleicht aufhören damit, der reinläuft über, Dinge passieren. Und tatsächlich, also das ist die krasseste Drohung, sorry, die ich habe, aber ich hab mal drei Dosen Red Bull nacheinander getrunken. Oh, Florentin, du bist so fucking hyperklimatisch. Das Loch ist sehr schnell zu erreichen bei dir, es muss nichts mehr. Ja, ich kippe den ganzen Tag Red Bull in das Loch rein, um es irgendwo zum Reden zu kriegen. Auch eine schöne Metapher, aber es ist tatsächlich ein Problem und du bist so fucking hyperaktiv und du merkst, wie du einfach anfängst, auch zu tanzen und Sachen zu machen. Und es ist tatsächlich ein großes Problem. Aber ich habe mir das Album von Lena Meyer-Landrut angehört und es war ein sehr schöner Abend. Das ist dein, oh fuck it ey, das ist das Ende einer Drogen-Story ist nie das Album von, oder es ist immer das Album von Lena Meyer-Landrut. Was ist denn Crystal Sky? What? Crystal Sky? Nein, Stardust. Das andere, Stardust. Ja, ja. No one can't catch us, nothing can change me, covered in Stardust, in the ground now, ihr Leben komplett ändern, aus München alleine nach Berlin zu ziehen, dort irgendwie in Moderation zu stehen und ein großer Fernsehstar zu werden. In dem Moment habe ich mir eingestanden, dass ich das Album von Lena Meilandroth eigentlich ganz geil finde. Bis dahin habe ich mich immer vor mir selbst geschämt, zu sagen, Popmusik und so, aber da hatte ich so viel Selbstbewusstsein. Das Album fand ich nicht gut. Ich fand mal Kissett-Player gut. Natürlich ist das Album nicht gut, aber wofür steht es gut?
Es steht dafür, dass sich das Selbstbewusstsein hat.
Nein, okay, das ist sehr unangenehm.
Das muss jetzt nicht sein.
Wir haben riesige Gema-Probleme, Stefan, auf gar keinen Fall.
Wenn ihr jetzt ein grosses Rabengekreische hört, dann ist es, weil ich versuche, den Song zu übertönen.
Aber, warte mal ganz kurz.
Wir müssen dabei reden, dann ist das nicht so schlimm. Da haben Gema nicht recht. Was das Geile an dem Album ist ... Das ist doch nicht das richtige Album. Warte mal ganz kurz. Ich glaube, das ist das einzige ... Halt mal die Fresse jetzt gerade. Das ist vor allem auch das falsche Lied, das passt überhaupt nicht. Vor allem, was das Geile an dem Album ist, dass es gibt die zwölf Titel, sagen wir mal, und dann gibt es nochmal zwölf Extra-Tracks, irgendwie so zwei Minuten lang. Die aber alle zu Recht nicht auf dem Album geschafft haben. Nein, wo der Anfang des Songs kommt und dann wird Lena Meyer-Landroth darüber interviewt, wie sie diesen Song geschrieben hat und wer alles diesen Song gemacht hat. Also Audio-Kommentare für eine CD? Ja, und es gibt zwölf Songs und dann nochmal zwölf Audio-Kommentare. Was, wie großartig ist das denn? Und das ist total strange, weil zum Beispiel wenn du es in der Zufallswiedergabe hörst, du immer nicht weisst, ob es das echte Lied ist oder nur der Anfang des Liedes und plötzlich fängt Lena Malandrut anzusprechen und erklärt ihr, wie sie das Lied gemacht hat. Und das ist echt, du wirst so wahnsinnig paranoid, weil auch wenn du einfach so sagst, alle Titel oder so hörst du, dann ist das ein Riesenproblem. Wir machen mal ganz kurz zum Beispiel Stardust Titelsong. Zeige ich jetzt mal, wie das anhört. ist wahrscheinlich die immer geschützt, ist mir egal. Okay, so geht's los.
Oh geil, Star-Dust, mein Lieblingssong, total emotionale Tiefe, geil, ich höre rein, ich liebe es.
Geil, cooler, cooler Song, richtig guter Beat, geht richtig rein.
Und dann, klar, lustlos ist jetzt nicht selber geschrieben.
Ja. selber geschrieben. Wer auch immer das ist. Warte mal, ist die ein Storyteller eigentlich? Ja, ich hänge an ihren Lücken. Ja, ja, ja, machen, machen, machen, machen. Der Text ist so wunderschön und passt auch wie die Faust aufs Auge, als hätte ich es selber geschrieben. Es ist vor allem, wenn man zu einem künstlerischen Beitrag nichts mehr sagen sollte als Künstler, ist es alles, eigentlich ist alles an Kunst. Man sollte als Künstler einfach die Fresse halten. Das Künstler sollte genug sagen. Als Song oder als Bild oder als Gag oder so, man sollte das nicht mehr sagen müssen. Ja, aber ich finde, zum Beispiel so Audiokommentaren von Regisseuren zu Filmen höre ich mir ganz gerne an, weil ich das Gefühl habe, da kann man noch tatsächlich was sagen. Geschichten vom Dreh, was passiert, was habe ich mir gedacht. Ah, bei Musik, bei Liedern, sie sagt immer dasselbe. Sie sagt immer, hey. Aber wenn sie es nur selber geschrieben hat. Ja, genau. Sie sagt immer. Sie ist nur zu erzählen, Hendrik und Tom haben es geschrieben. Aber vor allem, also das macht mich total paranoid und ich kann dieses Iron-Milch hören. Aber es ist auch nicht mal irgendwie so ein super. Und es ist auch nicht mal irgendwie so eine Stimme im Kopf, weil es sich nicht immer erklärt, warum dieses Lied nicht so gut ist. Und es ist tatsächlich nicht mal irgendwie so ein super... Die Stimme im Kopf, weil sich die haben erklärt, warum dieses Lied nicht so gut ist, wie man denkt.
Und es ist tatsächlich nicht mal irgendwie so ein super Deluxe-Fan-Edition-Album, sondern es ist ein stinknormaler Album, es ist ein ganz normaler Album, dass man sich anhört auf Spotify und ständig labert Lena Meyer-Landruth dazwischen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Geschichte.
Tatsächlich erinnert mich dieses Album an viele schöne Dinge und oft ist es ja die Musik eigentlich nur zweitrangig, sondern das, was man mit der Musik verbindet.
Das ist wie mit Gerüchen.
Oder mit Gerüchten. Oder mit Gerüchten. Und jetzt ist es ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein,, sondern das, was man mit der Musik verbindet. Das ist wie mit Gerüchen. Oder mit Gerüchten. Oder mit Gerüchten. Enhance your workplace. Oder mit Richtern. Oder mit Booster. Ich mag tatsächlich Lena Meyer-Landrot, das ist tatsächlich nicht so abwegig. Ich verstehe, dass sie arrogant ist und dass sie eine Schlampe ist und dass sie nicht cool ist und dass sie wirklich viel Leid über diese Welt gebracht hat, aber ich mag sie irgendwie. Ich weiss nicht warum. Keine Ahnung. Man kann ja auch nicht mehr erklären, warum man Leute mag. Ich habe gerne den Eurovision Song Contest geguckt und ich habe mich wirklich gefreut, als sie gewonnen hat. Man kann ja nicht immer erklären, warum man Leute mag. Es ist einfach mal nur so. Ich meine, oder? Ist das so? Wo sind wir jetzt? What? What? Also, wir haben genug. Stefan, ich mag dich.
Ich mag dich auch.
Und mit diesen Worten möchte ich mich verabschieden.
Das waren Florentin Will und Stefan die Tatze-Titze.
Das war wahrscheinlich die seltsamste, das Podcast-Ufo-Folge aller Zeiten.
Wir möchten uns gleichzeitig entschuldigen und uns auch freuen für eine Viertelstunde, die vielleicht ganz gut war.
Es muss manchmal auch kreatives Chaos geben. Ja, mit diesem Tipp verabschieden wir uns, das war Stefan Titzel und meine Sicherheit.
Und das war ein R2D2, Titzel meiner Meinung nach.
Dankeschön.
Vielen Dank, ein letztes Mal Körperkontakt, wir haben uns tatsächlich heute, we met at a very strange time.
Aber keine Angst, wir sind nie wieder in einem Raum zur gleichen Zeit.
Nee, auf gar keinen Fall.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Wir heben ab. Oh, auf gar keinen Fall. Das funktioniert nicht. Wir heben ab, oey, da kam ich an!